مع هذه الاسلحه توجد الدبابات طبعا وهي في
طخ الموت الان وهكذا يصفها من الان ماسك
الذي يستمر في اثاره الجدل وتعليقه جاءنا
ردا على تغريده من مصمم العاب الفيديو
ريتشارد جاريت الذي تساءلت عن فعاليه
الدبابات في القتال الحديث تزامنا مع شحنه
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا ينتظر ان تتضمن
مركبات المدرعه
احد ردود البارزه ايضا على تغريده ماسك
جاء من مارك هارت لينك وهو القائد العام
الاسبق للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا هارتلينج
اكد ان نظريه ماسك تكون صحيحه في حاله
واحده اذا كانت لديك دبابات سيئه اطقم غير
مدربه قياده سيئه اما في السيناريو
المعاكس فهي توفر امكانيه الوقائع على قيد
الحياه لطاقها وميزه كبيره في ساحه
المعركه كل هذه التعليقات اثار شكوكا حول
اقتراض انقراض الدبابات العسكريه بشكلها
الحليب من اعراض الميدان وذلك بسبب سهوله
الاستهداف لكن رغم ذلك تطلب اوكرانيا
المسيده منها رغم توفر بدائل بتكنولوجيا
متقدمه واسلحه بتقنيه فائقه لكنها غير
مستخدمه بحسب واشنطن بوست لدرجه جعلت
الحرب الحاليه في اوك تشبه الحرب العالميه
الاولى
معركه بخموط كذلك على الاقل